when you look into the pools of the 911
memorial at the world trade center
you start to ask yourself questions why
is the world
bad what did all these people die for
well for freedom i guess and like
american values but what are those
values
what kind of freedom is it that we have
the 911 memorial shares the world trade
center site with the largest shopping
mall in manhattan
there's a forever 21 an under armour a
kate spade
and a pair of shoes that i want but
they're too expensive and my feet are
too big and i'm too tall to wear high
heels anyway
ah [ __ ] neoliberalism
what even goes on in these big buildings
i've been looking at them all my life
but i've never been inside one
are these the towers where the ruling
lizards gather
drinking human blood licking whipped
cream off the interns
what the hell even is this country just
the same terrible [ __ ]
copy pasted all over the goddamn place
longhorn steakhouse
golden corral staples the red lobster
petsmart chipotle fridays dave and
busters
i guess it's not so bad as long as you
kick things up a notch
yes i want to add the lava cakes to my
order dominoes of course i want the
[ __ ] lava cakes
[Music]
i'm gonna put the cake on the pizza put
it all in me
fill me up
oh god damn it it was so good but i ate
so much i think i'm gonna die look what
capitalism made me do
of vast parts of territory all across
the middle east political dissent
begins with the vegas feeling that
something is wrong and a lot of people
have that feeling but the problem with
vague feelings is they can be channeled
in any direction
the same vague angst can drive people to
communism or fascism or anything in
between
there's a general sense today among
young people that we have been lied to
and that sense is perhaps the most acute
among middle class white men
who apparently were promised that they
could be millionaires
or movie gods or rock stars the term
special
snowflake is used today as a slur
against queer teenagers
but it comes from the movie fight club
where it refers to a generation of white
guys who have become adults
only to find that they're worse off than
their fathers that they don't have
glamorous jobs
they don't have girlfriends and more
recently that even in the escapist world
of video games their absolute
sovereignty is being challenged
i've devoted half my channel to
chronicling the deranged consequences of
this situation
anti-feminism alpha males pickup artists
the surreal surge in support for a white
ethnic homeland
but till now i haven't talked about the
underlying causes and it's important to
do that
because the thing is the white men
aren't even wrong
that society is screwing them in some
way it's just that it's screwing
everyone else
even more so the masculinist alt-right
analysis of society is exactly upside
down
guys you are not under the thumb of a
jewish feminist plot to turn you into
girly soyboy [ __ ]
cultural marxism did not turn you into
placid ikea consumers
capitalism did so what you need to do is
stop scapegoating non-whites
feminists and trans people and unite
with the rest of us to actually do
something about the real enemy
the blood-sucking god damn reptiles
chapter one capitalism and spirit oh god
i sound like a philosopher someone shoot
me
remember that nazi propaganda video
where richard spencer says that a
nation based on freedom is just another
place to go
shopping a leftist could easily have
said that we think of leftist analysis
as being very materialistic
but there's a spiritual dimension to it
too much of karl marx's early writings
are primarily concerned with the state
of the human soul under capitalism with
the alien nation of working not for
yourself but for an employer who
appropriates the value of your work with
the fetishism of commodities
the investment of inanimate objects with
transcendent properties beyond their
usefulness
with a system of lies and delusions by
which capitalism understands and
justifies itself
with [ __ ] comcast increasing my bill
to 70 a month for no [ __ ] reason no
i don't want a landline no one under the
age of 60 wants a landlord of course
it's not just marxists who complain
about a capitalist malaise
fascists and conservatives notice it too
only they think the solution is to seek
collective meaning in ancient customs
racial chauvinism
or fight clubs and that shit's not
really my scene i'm
really more of a pursuit of individual
happiness person but
i think that capitalism as we know it is
pretty bad at fostering individual
happiness
and here's why chapter 2 alienated labor
ah this marxist jargon
sucks let's come up with something new
chapter 2
shitty jobs why is your job so shitty
well probably it's because you work at
the comcast customer service call center
and you spend your day dealing with
whiny and titled white [ __ ] who don't
understand that you're just a lackey
without any actual power
and the system is organized so that
people with no power just have to
pointlessly shout at each other you
don't have any stake in the profit of
comcast as a company
so you don't really have any reason to
give a [ __ ] about the success of the
corporate machine in which you are a
gear
the ceo makes 36 million dollars a year
while you make 14
an hour which means that a lot of the
value of the work you're doing doesn't
get paid to you
but goes straight up the chain of
command and into the pockets of the
chief lizards
the ruthless hierarchical structure of
the company means that you're competing
against
your fellow employees for a promotion or
even to not be laid off
and if that happens you'll end up
competing against other unemployed
people for another
shitty job as a concrete lifter or a mud
mule
or maybe even a coffee shop macbook
person
this means it's difficult to even
experience companionship with the other
people in your shitty situation
because you're all being pitted against
each other by the goddamn reptiles
and it gets even worse you could be
employed by new age reptiles who force
you to participate in
team building exercises company
scavenger hunts
mandatory fun which means that not only
do you have a shitty oppressive job but
you're not even allowed the basic
pleasure of openly hating your life
you have to constantly pretend that
you're having fun all for the sake of
maintaining the overlord's comfortable
delusion that he's not your overlord
these lizards are smart and they keep
coming up with more elaborate ways to
lie to you
if you work for uber they won't even be
honest about the fact that you're their
employee
they'll call you an independent
contractor you get to be your own boss
and set your own hours
you only have to take out the initial
loan buy the car
pay the insurance pay for the cleaning
take on all the risk and give uber 25
without getting a guaranteed wage
benefits paid leave or pension
so much better than being an
old-fashioned employee right
now please don't transfer me to the
billing department they already
transferred me here chapter 3
advertising is it pretentious to use
chapters in a youtube video
what if each section is named after an
episode in the odyssey if you've lived
your life in america
you've spent every day since birth has
sailed from all directions by propaganda
campaigns for cereals
and cigarettes and sugar snacks
and now you can't get no satisfaction
jesus
people have been complaining about
advertising so long it's come to seem
like a basic feature of the human
condition but it's not a basic feature
of the human condition
it's a situation particular to life
under capitalism i mean north korea is a
dystopian [ __ ]
but at least the train station isn't
cluttered up with advertisements for
oh so many fans counterpoints is a tanki
confirmed
a near-liberal tanki the purpose of
advertising
is to manufacture desires which brands
across the world spend nearly 500
billion dollars a year doing the
ubiquity and apparent effectiveness of
advertising
seems to contradict one of the
fundamental assumptions of capitalist
society namely
that we're all autonomous individuals
making rational choices in pursuit of
our own well-being advertising uses a
lot of rhetorical strategies that are
not
very rational for instance randomly
correlating the product with sexual
desire generating new insecurities the
product promises to alleviate
associating the product with social
status associating the product with
random famous people associating the
product
with degenerate decadent associating the
product with progressive social
movements associating the product
with communist revolution gazing
longingly a dreamy argentinian
philosophy professor
join the clone army completely original
lighting gay orgies
love cannot survive without diamonds is
this rational
does it help people make genuine
decisions about their own best interests
of course not the goal of advertising is
not to satisfy the pre-existing needs
that people have
it's to endlessly create new needs and
that's a lot to keep up with and it
takes a lot of stamina which is why it's
a good thing i discovered vitalimax plus
every evening before i start writing or
shooting a video i insert two
vitalimax plus suppositories for a
sustainable blast in power
with all natural ginseng and opium
extracts vitalimax plus gives me the
reckless euphoria
and indifference to pain that i need to
get it
in i start with a couple dozen oysters
eat some molly maybe hit a couple
animals
then i take my vitalimax plus and i'm
ready to rip
it by talamax
for bottoms consumer society is all
about goddamn lizards inventing desires
which they implant in your brain through
advertising
then they sell you the product that
fulfills the desire that they invented
irrespective of whether the fulfillment
of the desire actually contributes to
your well-being in any way so what we
have is a society built not around
meeting basic human needs or maximizing
human happiness
but around the extravagant profits of
powerful reptiles
who tell you what to want and then sell
it to you and this would be a grim state
of affairs in any circumstances but it's
especially egregious in a country where
many of the basic needs are not met
on the one hand we have 40 million
people living in this country with
medical debt
spiraling tuition costs leading college
students to take out loans they may
never escape
more than half a million homeless people
and 13 million children who have to go
to school hungry
and on the other hand we apparently have
the resources to mass produce 400
juice packets squeezing machines and 300
luxury ice cubes and there were
apparently americans who are willing to
spend
50 million dollars on barnet newman
paintings i mean it's a fine painting
it's got a lot of great red on it
but is it really worth the cost of
feeding every homeless person in america
for two weeks
is this what an efficient economy looks
like if gdp is your only measure of
efficiency
then maybe but shouldn't the economy
serve humanity rather than the other way
around
if millions of people are struggling
under the weight of student debt
underemployment and outrageous medical
costs then who gives a [ __ ] how many
golden donuts we can
[Music]
what do i do produce the gold on my
fingers canto4 message to the rich
all right you filthy goddamn reptiles
listen up
i have a pretty good barometer for
internet politics which is to say
politics i mean i noticed the alt-right
thing pretty early and you can assign as
much
or as little significance to that as you
choose but what i'm picking up at the
moment is that people are getting
[ __ ] mad
and they're starting to get mad
specifically at you the rich and you
don't just have to trust my intuitions
here
recent polling data shows that a
majority of adults under the age of
30 do not support capitalism and almost
a third support
socialism this is not the 80s anymore
you can't continue to get richer and
richer while the rest of the country is
underemployed
in debt and unable to afford health care
what you're doing has been tried before
and it doesn't end well you can't just
stroll around town dressed like this
and live in houses like this when there
are millions of peasants who don't have
enough to eat
they will eventually try to cut your
heads off and judging by the mood i'm
picking up on social media right now
if you don't fix some [ __ ] and make life
better for the masses they are gonna cut
your [ __ ] heads off i mean they won't
actually cut your heads off but they
will try
and you'll have to deploy militarized
police and you will crush them
ruthlessly but it's gonna be a whole
thing
bad for profits and just all around a
real inconvenience for you
nosy humanitarians will butt their heads
in and they're gonna make things awkward
the point is [ __ ] cannot continue the
way it's going something is gonna have
to change
we can do this the easy way or the hard
way the choice
is up to you
well are you going to answer the phone
there is no phone there is only the side
of the oppressed creature
the heart of a heartless world the soul
of a soulless condition it's best to
just try and ignore it
episode 5 message to the youth all right
kids so you're angry
well good the world sucks there's a lot
to be angry about
what we have to do next is decide what
to do with that anger
i don't think tweeting aggressively is
gonna cut it so
what do we do smash
gabby get in here sit down
[Music]
look i know i've been kind of hard on
you harsh words have been exchanged
but i need young radicals like you in my
life the minute i stop listening to
people like you
is the minute i become irrelevant so i
apologize
i never meant to hurt you baby i'm sorry
i mean look i get it smashing is fun but
we also need to have a real plan that's
all i'm saying
so what's the plan revolution okay
yeah revolution i mean you're right
donald trump is president
[ __ ] it revolution we've got to get
better people in office
we've got to vote in a whole different
kind of politician right
no revolution yeah yes i know revolution
but what kind of revolution like
project mayhem gather your muskets ye
militia men and water the tree of
liberty what
no i mean direct action okay so like a
general strike
no and capitalism
[Music]
tabby i'm not trying to say i have all
the answers here because i really don't
but i think we should at least try to
come up with something a little more
substantive than just
saying the word revolution like i'm in
support of radical movements
occupy wall street 1960s uprisings i
think these kinds of movements can
generate a lot of energy
they shift the overton window to the
left and they can have a big cultural
impact but none of them so far has ended
capitalism
and capitalism needs the state to
maintain its power and we can change the
state through electoral politics so why
not direct some serious energy toward
that
well revolutions have worked in russia
and china but no elected politician has
ever even come close to ending
capitalism in the us
so why do you think that will work
what's to stop whoever you elect
from getting absorbed by the same
corrupt finance backed system that every
politician eventually has to swear
allegiance to well you're not entirely
wrong
but on the other hand chinese and soviet
communism were not exactly
super great and in any case i'm having a
little bit of trouble imagining a 1917
style revolutionary army marching down
pennsylvania avenue in 2018.
shouldn't we focus on protecting
abortion and getting affordable health
care and education
and ending mass incarceration and other
achievable goals what if the 2020
election is postponed
well then i will transition into you and
become you unironically why not just be
honest about your political stance
are you a democratic socialist or would
you actually support a revolution well i
prefer to just describe my positions and
let others decide on the labels
now for you contra points i mean you're
still a heretic in an enemy of the
imperium and you are a demonet of
slaanesh and everything like that but i
still like you
[Music]
but what exactly are your positions um
well
kill everyone now condone first degree
murder
advocate cannibalism eat [ __ ] filth are
my politics
eat reptiles why do you keep saying
reptiles when you mean capitalists oh
because marxist analysis is boring
and it's more interesting if the
capitalists are reptiles but you sound
like a conspiracy theorist
aren't you discrediting yourself by
using david ike's vocabulary well
david ike is selling a lot of books can
the same be said of horkheimer have you
read horkheimer
yes have you read krapotkin yes have you
read bakunin
no you really can't understand these
issues until you've read bakunin
have you read placonos have you read
goldman
have you read zetkin have you read
graham sheep
have you read grindelwald have you read
slobodan's arthusian
have you read sexist arcanists have you
read [ __ ] skenorevsky happy
i have a phd in reading tedious
blowhards and i'm telling you right now
i ain't reading any of that [ __ ]
and if being an encyclopedia of
long-winded eastern bloc gibberish is a
prerequisite for talking to you then no
one is going to listen to what you have
to say
i think i'm just gonna go this isn't
really working out
wait tabby before you go
let me say one more thing
if you ever change your mind
oh baby bring it to me bring
your sweet lovin bring it on to me
yeah yeah
i know when you left
but now i only i only hurt myself
oh baby bring it to me bring your sweet
[Music]
all i do for you oh
baby bring it to me bring your sweet
love
bring it on home to me yeah
yeah i know i always
be your slave until i'm buried
buried in my grave tabby
bring it to me bring yours
[Music]
girl unsubscribed
it's [ __ ] 2018 man